τέσερα διριορδανικά δύο από τας συμβάσεις που έχουμε και τα πόλιπα τω τον μάω άραμέχρι
τω μάγιο θα έχουμε έντεκα προτεύοντα θητικά μέσα συτα υπόλευα που υπάρχουν έχουμε κάμει ως
κυβέρνηση ο πρόεδρος της δημοκρατίας αποφάσειση την μεταφορά της μονάδα ψητικόμέσω στην εθνική φρονώ μια
πολύ σημαντικ έτσι απόφαση και προχωρά τνήμαδα σ ήταπρόκεψε για το σκάνταλο πως εφθάσε κοντά
σα το συγκεκριμένο θέο εννοείται με της τπως καταγύνηθαμε ταξι πρώτα ν μαστε σιλί θα
ιοθετήσει ότι λέξη σκάνδαλο και τού τον γιατί ι οι έρευνα πινική ρευνα της αστυνομίας
νακόμα σεξέλιξη πρώτα ν έμαστε προσεκτική η για να μην μολύνουμε την όποια δι αδικασία
για αυτόν το αγό το λέω αξη είχαείχε έρθει μια καθαγκελία κοντά καθικών τος ζήτησανα
γίνει διερεύνηση για όλες πλαον της της συμβάσεις που ήταν ενεξελίξε από το δκά εφτά
μέχρι και εκείνη την περίω εντο πίστηκαν τα ποιαιστιχεία ανημερώσαμε την αστιών και από κι
ακολούθησε τα πράγματα το δρόμο τος είναι για τη μόνη για το μόνο τμήμα που
έφθασε κοντά σο πληροφορία ότι μπορεί να υπάρχει το ότι δήποτε μετο μόνο τμήμα πω
σχετίζετι με το υπουργίο γεοργίος ενδεχόμεν έρεύνες για ενδεχόμενα πιθα αρχικά αδικήματα πορεί να προκύπτουν
για όποιο τίποτε επτιμήμα να ανάλογο και με τη θεματικίτου νκαιντούτ το θέμα τούτετο θέμαν
ένα κγίνο το οποίο έχει σημασία είναιταν έρχεται κάτι κοντά μας να το διερευνούμε και
αν υπάρχει ο ποιο τίποτε εντεχόμενον να καταδεικμεί είτε επιθααρχικά είτε πινικά να διερευνούνται και
τού τον πρέπει να γίνεται πρώττο για να μ